-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late night."
We hope
you're doing well tonight.
Now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden
yesterday announced
an additional $200 million
in funds for Ukraine,
which is great, but it's not
enough money to fight a war.
It's barely enough money
to make a movie about a war.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Ukrainian President Zelenskyy
spoke with lawmakers yesterday
on Capitol Hill
and said, "Keep your weapons.
Just give me this guy."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden has reportedly
told confidants
that he feels guilty about
his son Hunter's legal issues,
and feels that Hunter wouldn't
be facing criminal prosecutions
if he had not run
for president in 2020.
Hell, with his résumé,
Hunter would probably
be looking at a spot
in Trump's cabinet.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
"Secretary of parties."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Former President Trump
is selling pieces of the suit
he wore during his mugshot.
Or for 10 bucks, you can
just go to a Joseph A. Bank
and get the whole thing.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
former President Trump
is selling pieces of the suit
he wore during his mugshot.
You know, like billionaires do.
[ Laughter ]
You think Rupert Murdoch
would sell you his suit?
If he thought
you wanted his suit,
he would burn it
in front of you.
[ As Murdoch ]
There you go, mate.
Take all the ashes you want!"
[ Normal voice ] CNN hosted
a town-hall event last night
in Iowa with
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis.
It's a rare example
of a sentence in which "Iowa"
is the most interesting word.
[ Laughter ]
The FBI arrested
an Internet-pornography
personality last week
for allegedly participating
in the attack on the Capitol.
He was the one who went
in the rear entrance.
I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
I don't know what happened.
Let me try again.
I apologize.
The FBI arrested
an Internet-pornography
personality last week
for allegedly participating
in the attack on the Capitol.
Well, you didn't get Mike Pence,
but at least one guy was hung.
[ Laughter ]
Hmm.
We fixed it.
[ Laughter ]
According to new survey,
40% of millennials think
that couples should talk
about finances
before a relationship
gets serious.
Said one millennial couple,
"We're good."
[ Laughter ]
In an effort to stop
Smith & Wesson
from manufacturing
assault rifles,
a group of Catholic nuns
recently filed a lawsuit
against the gunmaker,
but only because they prefer
a more traditional
assault weapon.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the makers
of Doritos
have announced a partnership
with the flavor company
Empirical to offer
a nacho-cheese-flavored alcohol.
It's a perfect way to celebrate
when Maury says,
"You're not the father."
[ Laughter ]
-And that was the monologue,
everybody.
We're off and running.
[ Cheers and applause ]